you had a nice part in this is where I
leave you
and I'm check out the movie and you have
a very striking nude scene a graphic
full nude scene yeah yeah and I would
think that would be nerve-wracking it
was incredibly nerve-racking and I don't
want to put you in a box on this but I
do think we both suffer from tall white
guy syndrome which is this whole white
watery eye white where your back just
goes into your legs there's really no
butt cheeks there so I have these buns
and so I spent a lot of time just doing
lunges and squats and one because I knew
they were gonna be on full display yeah
I also got self-conscious of the fact
that while I don't have a lot of hair on
the cheeks they're nice you know there's
there's an ample amount there's a forest
in the valley fear would look like there
was like a werewolf trying us great
escape my butt crack so I asked Kristen
they don't want ain't gettin out no no I
like that guy he's a good actor but he
is a werewolf so though I asked Kristen
to my life Kristen Bell Chris I saw the
beautiful Kristen Bell that people can
already not understand how she's with me
got the pleasure of help you know why
didn't you go to a professional or oh
that would be great turn this over to a
stranger
you imagine not your wife you're
beautiful she's the only person I would
feel come I didn't even feel comfortable
her doing it it was a terrible
experience and is there a special tool
that no just off the off the shelf or
you know electric razor that you would
trip you trim your dog with or something
you know battery-powered Clippers and I
don't know why I think she had some
nervous energy going but while she was
trimming it she was humming doo doo doo
doo doo doo doo doo doo - gotta move on
now so vulnerable and weird and then she
was singing that song yeah well she took
a trip to town
you